Alright guys, so here is the example number one for the ICT silver bullet
you can see that
Over here we do not have a clear liquidy sweep anywhere and the time is 955 right
So we're gonna wait for this for the price to either take out the buy side or the sell side
So you can see price took out the sell side here
So now here's the thing price can take out liquidy even when even after 10 a.m
Okay, there is no like rule that the liquidity sweep must happen before 10
Okay, the thing is your entry must only be after 10
So it has taken out the you know the sell side. Let's go back to one minute and
Look for a clear
market structure shift and
As you can see right here what we do have is a lower low lower high lower low
Right and then over here we have a shift in market structure now
This I consider
Internal market structure and this right here would be my external market structure
Okay, so let's say a price takes out this significant high over here
Then the chances of that trade playing out is gonna be decreased. I want these tiny structures to break
Okay, I do not want want this like a significant structure to break because if that breaks in my eyes
That is a liquidity sweep especially when we're looking at one minute time from so now what we do have is a favorably gap right here
Okay, and my entry would go here
so let's say that we put our stop at five handles right here and we go for
five handles take profit, right and the time is 10 36 and
Your entry must not be later than 10 50 10 50 a.m. Okay, so your window the trading period is
10 a.m
Oops 10. Oh my god
50 a.m
All right, so your entry must happen during this time window, okay?
And you must close your trade before 11. Okay, so we have our entry and let's see how this plays out
We go back in a little draw down here and then look at that we push back up right away
So that take profit was it however if you held your trade
Till this level you can see we would have gotten one to two risk to war trade
So it needs some sort of practicing and then you can master this strategy
Remember this is very important part here
When a significant structure something like that if it breaks and then it comes back to your entry that is a low probability setup
I want so let's say you have a liquidity sweep, right? This is a little receive. I want this tiny structure something like that, okay?
Not something like this where you have like three four or let me give you another example
That's right here if that breaks right that is invalid. I want to see a break of structure something like you know
this over here or
Maybe you see lower low lower high lower low something like that. That is prime market structure or this is the best example
Right here, okay. You see this tiny structure here lower low lower high lower low
I do not want to see this structure break and then I wait for my entry that is invalid
You can see that we broke the structure and we filled in this very valley gap and then we went down
Because this is liquidity guys a lot of people what they do is they consider this as the low and they consider this as
You know market structure shift. No, that is a liquidity sweep. Okay, just open your eyes, bro
So right here we hit one to two. Let me give you guys another example